[Music]
inside of you is brought to you by sonos
uh you know i love this company you know
i love this product i had them all over
my house before they were a sponsor i've
been begging cumulus to
and the ladies at cumulus agnes and
teresa please get me sonos get sonos on
as a sponsor and finally
they do
i can't tell you how much i love sonos
you know how a lot of times you have
these clunky receivers and all you know
speakers and all these things in your
house and you could just minimize
everything and make life simple with
sonos a sono speaker that you could play
a different song in each room you could
play party mode outside you can go
listen to some of the sundays downstairs
if you know who the sundays are i like
the sundays
um
it's really a wonderful product i
haven't heard anyone bad mouth sonos i
say to my friends they say you know what
sono says like oh my god of course sonos
i know sonos stonies yeah sonos man oh
my god i knew sannius yeah and stennis
that was awesome sonos has a new product
called rome and uh this is such a sleek
cool product and um it looks amazing in
my home and i really urge you to check
it out uh it's in my office and uh the
sound is unbelievable that's just the
thing you don't need these big speakers
these big bulky things in your house
anymore these ceiling speakers you got
you got sonos and rome is just really
amazing and uh durable
and um
i really like it sonos rome is the ultra
portable smart speaker that allows you
to bring the sonos experience everywhere
you go rome weighs less than a pound and
its premium durable design makes it
perfect for the home and for on the go
thanks ryan you know when you're at home
roam connects to your wi-fi network and
the rest of your sonos system and then
automatically pairs with your phone on
bluetooth when you're on the go for a
seamless experience using automatic true
play tuning roams smartly adapts to your
surroundings and whatever you're
listening to and creates sound that's
astonishingly detailed and perfectly
balanced control roam using the app
apple airplay 2 or your voice with an
amazon alexa or google assistant with
sonos you can start with one speaker
expand your system over time like i have
i think i have nine in my house
all sonos speakers connect over wi-fi so
you can group speakers in different
rooms and play music throughout your
home you know i love sonos again because
it's like if you got a girlfriend or
whatever you know it's like she's like i
want to listen to whatever and you're
like well i want to listen to like this
and you can go well i'm going to go to
my room well your room is my room okay
you go to your our room i'm going to go
downstairs and listen just imagining you
and a wig yeah well there you go i've
been in wigs before i've been in a lot
of movies sonos we love our sonos please
go to sonos.com to learn more you will
not be sorry sonos.com
you are listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum how are you everyone
happy new year to you i hope you're
doing well ryan good to see you again
good to see you again yeah we had jason
in here uh
for you yeah he sounded nice
it was fun i'm bummed i didn't get to
meet him uh i still haven't met him in
person but he just seems like a
chill-ass dude yeah he's so chill and he
was welling was like dude that dude was
hilarious i'm like yeah
uh he is chill i wish i was as chill as
him yeah even you aren't as chill as i
am not as childish she's it's like it
goes from it goes from very chill to
unchill
dropping like life truth bombs just like
out of nowhere that's great yeah way to
go jay way to go
um great guest today jensen ackles we'll
get into that but uh hey if you like the
podcast i know if you're here for jensen
you love jensen you love supernatural
you love the boys you're here for gents
and you're not here for me and i i could
i could deal with that
but all i'm asking is if you enjoy the
interview why not listen to another one
why not subscribe write a review and be
like hey i like this dude or i think it
was a good interview unless you think it
sucks and then
[ __ ] it
you know
um
you ryan by the way you just got back
from hawaii i was in hawaii for two
weeks i don't want to say you look to
shovel because you look good but you
your uh disposition when you when i
walked in it just felt like you were
like
it's a long time to be anywhere really
with your girlfriend girlfriend
girlfriend's family uh so not my family
so it's a lot of uh being uh
you know just with anyone
something
you gotta turn something off you turn it
on it's not totally natural right it's
like it's not like you're trying to like
them you like them but it's like you're
putting on something extra as you're not
feeling as lazy yeah and it wears you
down it does yeah after a while the
first week was great you know we hung
out with nieces we did a lot of fun
stuff and like adventures and things and
like we went on a little hike to a
waterfall nice uh a lot of pickleball
i'm gonna pickleball oh good let's play
some pickleball let's do it i would play
pickleball show me how to play
pickleball i'm good at it now yeah it's
it's like uh you can play at any tennis
court uh they have to have like little
lines for it some of them yeah some of
them probably do a bit i bet you they do
um but yeah after it's hard to do for
more than a week i'll say dude i'm my
dad while you were gone my dad was in
town for three days yeah and he came in
on a friday and left on a
came on saturday morning and left on a
tuesday morning so he was barely here
three days and your toast
yeah
took him to the lakers game took just
you know his 70th birthday and i kind of
just like really
you know lived it up uh wanted him to
live it up and yeah i think he really
enjoyed himself and that was the good
thing but uh you know there was moments
where i just was like
you know there's those are the moments
where you just want to say something you
know it's going to start an argument so
you don't do it
you just don't do it we're good on you
but look he had a great time that's all
i care about and uh you know it was nice
it was not you know we had some nice
times and uh so there was that but you
know you know i i'm thinking three days
and you you're talking two weeks i would
[ __ ]
no no offense dad i'd [ __ ] jump off a
roof
mom if you're listening i know you both
you aren't you don't even probably know
i have a podcast but i would jump off
the [ __ ] roof
and that's no that's no lie
hey guys if you like the show
follow us uh the handles are inside of
you podcast on twitter and instagram
please follow us and at insideapod on
the twitter um write a review on whether
you're listening on spotify whether
you're watching on youtube whatever
you're doing write a review it really
helps the show especially on apple
uh write a review tell us what you think
um we're gonna get into jensen i promise
just here in a second but you know those
things to talk about i want to say happy
new year to you i also want to say that
uh my band sunspin rob and i are playing
a show we haven't played in two months
so if you haven't watched the show or
you know come to a virtual show i urge
you to check us out it's you just go to
stageit.com st in fact go to sunspin.com
that's the name of the band and you get
tickets on sunspin.com on upcoming shows
we're playing january 29th 2 p.m and 6
p.m pacific standard time
covers originals uh there's zooms prizes
all that [ __ ] i hope you you join us
also join the lovely patron uh patrons
um if you go to patreon.com inside of
you
these people
these patrons of mine follow the podcast
support the podcast and want it to keep
going so if you like the podcast and you
want to give something why not be a
patron
so there's that uh what else i'll be in
la molle
right at the limo limouli i don't know
convention in mexico
nice in march cool limouli yeah i don't
know yeah it'll be fun i went there
before it's great great people great
time we're gonna do a smallville nights
event with me and tom two-man show we're
gonna sign autographs
we love mexico is that where mole sauce
originated i don't know that stuff's
good is it oh yeah right like the thick
oxygen dark so i'll try some mole sauce
oh you can get anywhere around here holy
moly yeah
um
if you want any merch uh go to the
inside of you online store we've got
i've got like lexmas uh scripts from
smallville
uh that you have signed and pictures and
inside of you tumblers and just a bunch
of fun stuff hats shirts so check out
the inside of you online store and you
can also get merch for the band
sunspin.com and that's pretty much it
we're working on a new album so we're
performing on these virtual shows for
stage it anyway let's get into it
um this is a great great interview um
he's always a treat to talk to
um he's he's on the boys he's you're a
supernatural guy
he's he's
i just love talking to him he was in
person and that was fun it was nice to
have him here in person and i really
think you're gonna enjoy this interview
and uh let's get inside of jensen ackles
it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
yeah you know i love howard stern but
like one time he started going on a rant
about all these actors and all these
people have podcasts it's like who the
hell are listening to i'm like dude
you're a billionaire you have like a hit
show the biggest show in the history of
talk radio what do you care about like
other people doing what they love to do
and what they like that's his space man
he's king of media he's the king of
media i love howard but jesus man like
give me a break it's like i'm doing i
think i'm doing a decent job here and uh
you know
you know howard's one of my heroes this
is uh
this is such a unique space i just had a
meeting yesterday with one dre
onedri yeah they're uh they've been a
sponsor laundry
yep
um they're uh they're heavy in the
podcast game yes why are you thinking
about doing a podcast no i was just
trying to get a better idea of what the
hell is going on in that space could you
imagine like you know tom and i have
thought about this willing from
smallville in case you'd you wonder who
i'm talking about i mean you know but
like if you refer to somebody by their
first name i assume i know who they are
well i don't want people to think that
i'm assuming they know who i'm talking
about or whatever like tom you know and
you're like like oh this is an inside
conversation i didn't think you were
talking about tom barringer right i
assumed you were talking about welling
yeah but he was
he was going you know what if we did
something where we like science mystery
3000 as that was called
mystery science theater mystery science
theater
now they're doing these things well we
watched episodes of smallville and talk
to people and commentate and stuff it's
like you know then i was thinking wow if
you and jared got together and did like
episodes and had a podcast that you did
here and there and you had like you know
you talked about each episode so funny
enough uh during the uh during the the
lockdown last year 2020.
remember when krazynski did that some
good news thing he came out with it was
like a youtube thing and it was just
from home and his kids were decorating
the background and stuff and i saw a few
episodes of that that gave me an idea
very similar to what you were just
talking about right uh of course i'm
just there with with with danielle and
the kids and we're just trying to not
lose our minds um right you don't need
any more projects right now right but
but i also am like i can't stay idle
like i just i'm like
we're in lockdown i don't know what's
happening i'm like we got to do
something creative so we literally came
up with a concept similar to that where
where she and i would watch
fan favorite episodes
and then talk about them but the but the
catch was is i obviously lived it
right she hadn't she's she could
probably count on one hand how many full
episodes of supernatural she's
a good wife good wife um well i mean to
her uh
um argument she's you know she's got
three rugrats to to follow and why would
she want to watch 300 episodes of a
television show that her husband's on i
mean maybe a couple that you're like hey
i'd like you to watch this one
yeah
and she's seen those yeah um or even
just moment scenes you know hey check
out this this this scene right um
but i thought that would have been
interesting so we actually shot a pilot
we actually set up all the iphones and
ipads and we
we made a set
we had uh we had misha call in and as a
zoom guest
and we we critiqued uh it was his his
first episode lazarus rising we we we
went and did an entire pilot and then
all of a sudden like uh tnt and cw were
like we want it and they're like we want
you to do like 10 episodes once what one
a week and we're going to broadcast
we're going to air it on broadcast
television are you going to do it
no this was a year ago and i was like i
was like i can't i can't produce 10
episodes of television while i'm on
lockdown with three kids
like they're that could have been really
funny though with kids coming in and out
and like just doing it doing the best
you can i was like just to have this
conversation i've drugged all three of
them and they're in a pile in the other
room like this is that's not tenable
so
so we we graciously passed but uh um but
that led to some other cool stuff you
know i was looking on you know wiki and
all these other things and you know i
know that you started out doing soap
operas and stuff we talked about that
you know i mean you were modeling at a
young age like as a kid
yeah but it was like you know the
jcpenney's catalog
still pajamas but but you were still
like you were in the i was in front of
the camera in front of the camera in
that space but i was like i didn't know
you won like a soap opera digest award
you were nominated for emmys and things
like that yeah like that's a big deal
yeah and as like a as a young i mean i
was i came out to l.a at 18. i think it
was on the soap at 19 and i was going to
award shows in new york
you know before i was even before my
21st birthday
so i didn't really understand the
you know the weight of all that i was
just like
this is easy
see
what's amazing is how you think it's
easy and i'm like looking like
nothing terrifies me more
than the thought of doing a soap opera
because they do like four five six
episodes a day tell me if i'm wrong and
there's like sometimes you have 30 pages
of dialogue is that correct so it's uh
and i'm sure it's changed a little bit
since i've been there but i remember
is it's about it's an episode a day
but these episodes are you know you're
talking 60 pages right this is an
hour-long drama a lot of dialogue
so they're shooting at least 60 pages a
day jesus a day
um were you stressed
no because you come in i mean i was at
again i was young and i didn't i didn't
even ignorance was a bliss at that point
right right
you can do anything yeah but it i i will
give uh daytime actors all the credit in
the world because uh
you get you essentially get one take per
scene
and we're talking a two and a half three
to five page scenes even if it's
emotional yeah they want one take one
take to move it if you didn't
horribly mess up the dialogue
if you didn't if you you know if you hit
your mark and you at least got through
the dialogue in some some form or
fashion
they're moving on they don't have time
to wait for you i once did 12 scenes in
an hour
i i just can't even imagine that i mean
you say youth helps that sort of thing
and you're kind of like wet behind the
ears and you're just like yeah yeah yeah
whatever yeah but like i mean that's a
lot of lines it's a lot of dialogue and
that's i mean you open any drawer or
under any couch cushion on any daytime
set there are their sides do you have a
photographic memory can you learn
something very quickly yeah
maybe i i i actually envision the page
in my mind and i'm and i i see that it's
almost like a teleprompter in my head so
you rarely even mess up
um
i i know i mean i i i can hiccup but
for instance just uh recently when i was
up in toronto shooting the boys
um
they uh
they dropped some pocket dialogue on me
uh on the day like an hour before we
were about to shoot this thing
you did your nerves that kind of get
like a little frazzled it was like it
was a full interview
like an on-camera interview with like
you know
lengthy responses that i was supposed to
to give
and i ran through it with the with
scripty and and then i was like and then
i had this idea i was like how about
this instead of you asking the questions
of the interviewer and me giving the
response
you just read my lines to me instead of
the questions that you're asking and
i'll just repeat what you're saying
so we did that for a couple days and
then i was like never mind i've got it
and then there's just like that and then
we went back that's terrifying for me
for someone it's happened before where
they're like hey we got the scene that
came up it's three pages they just sent
it in we're gonna shoot this after lunch
and it ruins my day
it ruins my [ __ ] day i like to
prepare
prep know what i'm doing feel loose on
set and then when someone throws that at
me but you don't get really nervous you
just kind of adjust i mean i'll i'll get
i won't even get pissy i'll i'll just be
like i'll just be like come on and then
i'll know in my head i'm like
i'm they're gonna i'm gonna do it i'm
gonna do like i'm gonna give it to them
right they're gonna get it
but i'm just like
that's not cool man
and
and then i'm just like well i could sit
here and [ __ ] about it or take the time
to just
or just get it done and move on and i i
usually pick the ladder
inside of you is brought to you by our
good friends at geico
if you don't know the name geico folks i
don't know what to tell you but geico
you're talking about great rates you're
talking about a name that everybody
knows
and uh you know whether you rent your
home like ryan you own your home i'm
lucky enough to own my home but you know
the biggest
issue i think people have is is paying
their rent paying their mortgage that
that's the big thing
you know and on top of it you got all
these other bills
and so geico's got this bundling policy
ryan
have you heard the bundling policy have
you heard of the button i've heard of
the bundling policy of course you could
uh bundle your homeowners or renters
insurance along with your auto policy
it's a good thing because we're very
busy and
these things every little thing helps
guy geico's making your life easier and
all you have to do
is go to geico.com
get a quote
see how much you can save it's geico
easy visit
geico.com today that's geico.com even a
rosenbomb can do it inside of you is
brought to you by better help boy uh
i'll tell you if it's one sponsor that i
could really relate to and uh not that i
don't relate to all the others that i do
but better help online therapy
uh i'll tell you it's changing lives
it's helping people all across the world
so many of my friends are doing it using
it ryan you use better help how's your
therapy going it's going very well yeah
i feel like you got a good therapist now
and you're uh you're happy i yeah i am i
do uh yeah it's great and you use it uh
at least every month yeah no once a week
once a week once a week i have a video
chat session and you know the uh yeah
the text chat is always open so if
there's any any issues
or
someone's got a lesson for you then yeah
it's great so you just text them
you know people think you should wait
until things are are unbearable to go to
therapy
and that's co that couldn't be further
from the truth therapy is a tool to
utilize before things get worse and it
can help you avoid those lows
sometimes we just wait till everything's
just hit the fan and then we go i need
therapy
if you feel like you're starting to lose
a little control if you feel like you're
starting to
feel that depression anxiety you just
need someone else to talk to
someone objectively
better help online therapy folks many
people think therapy is for so-called
crazy people
but therapy doesn't mean something's
wrong with you it means you recognize
that all humans have emotions and we
need to learn to control them
not avoid them and we've been taught
that mental health shouldn't be a part
of normal life
but that's wrong we take care of our
bodies with the gym
the doctor and nutrition we should be
focusing on our minds just as much and i
i
wholeheartedly agree
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to i like to see them so
does ryan yeah it's much more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours give it a try and see why over 2
million people have used better help
online therapy inside listeners get 10
percent off
by going to
better
help
dot com slash inside that's better help
b e t t e r h e l p dot com slash inside
do yourselves a favor
get some help
well we're gonna get into the boys yeah
we're gonna get into that we're gonna
get into a lot of stuff but
you know i mean i look at your work and
you i know you did dark angel and you
know by the way was jessica alba cool to
work with no she was horrible
are you kidding no no no she was not fun
to work with well i will tell you i've
told her i've told this to her face
really
why so what makes an actor or an actress
what makes them tough to work with i i
uh i love jess um
which i know kind of contradicts what i
just said but this is no secret you're
saying yeah no she she um
she was under an immense amount of
pressure on that show
she was young
uh she was in a
um she was in a relationship with um
one of the guys right yep and
and
that was
that was rocky uh and
causing some some undue stress i believe
on set
and i was like the new
the new
fresh face on the set who wasn't really
there in season one i came in for one
episode but then they wrote me in as a
series regular season two
and i was just kind of
i was i was the new kid on the block and
i i got i got picked on by the lead and
she picked on oh yeah explain
oh i mean
like
like the worst kind of bickering a
brother and sister could do
she just she had she had it out for me
she like she didn't like you
i don't know if it would no it wasn't
that she didn't like me she just was
like oh oh here's the pretty boy that
that network brought in for some more
window dressing because that's what we
need
in front of the whole crew yeah
and you just kind of just well and very
quickly i was like
what the [ __ ]
like what
what did i do he's ass yeah so very
quickly i was just like well
fire with fire
so you fought back so i just was like oh
looks like we're getting [ __ ] alba
today
really everybody hang on to your hang
under your nuts and the crew loved it oh
loved it and she kinda did she like it
and well it just then she was like okay
well now i can now i can just
be a dick to him and he'll be a dick to
me and that's how we'll roll
that's amazing and and it and it did it
did build some mutual respect
so you got along as the time when you
know she was under a lot of pressure you
know she was kind of [ __ ] at times
yeah and eventually you kind of accepted
it but she kind of got okay touche
touched jesus but we but we bickered we
bickered like brother and sister but
then like you know there were moments
uh uh
you know when uh when her guy was away
she didn't like to
she was like scared of this house that
they were running and so she asked me to
come over and just keep her company
so i did provocative that's well
i guess it could have been but i just
knew i was like no this is very this is
very platonic very brother sister jesus
but then like got me over her house to
keep her company yeah
no trust me looking back i i shake my
head at like jesus did i miss something
there yeah like something like just tone
deaf like hey pretty boy in a nightgown
hey pretty boy
no she would have kicked me the nuts if
i tried anything right um
which she if she was she's very very
tough little
woman little vixen vixen yeah uh but
again like my grandfather died while i
was shooting and she literally just
walked into my trailer and just held me
for you know half an hour all right so
so there there was it was that kind of a
relationship right and again if you know
she walked in we'd be all hugs right but
but it was
she didn't make it easy
on me do you remember going back home
after set after a long day and talking
to one of your buddies going damn man
she gives me such [ __ ] hell yeah i was
like i feel like i'm getting bullied
here were you nervous at all will it
make you kind of like like [ __ ] the lead
doesn't like me she's gonna get me fired
no because i forget who it was but a
friend of mine was like
um
i
was like
what did you say it gave me kind of some
sort of a confidence booster of like
well she's intimidated by you or she
likes you
or she likes you or something which i
mean i just told myself that just to
kind of give me the confidence that i
needed to kind of get through the day
right but uh
unfortunately it only went one more
season and then that was that but also
speaking of like you know stars dating
people while they're filming and that
creates a lot of problems most the time
you also run dawson's creek for the
final season yep now a lot of these
actors were dating each other there's a
lot of hookups and things right this is
like we're talking like 20 years ago
yeah but like i i you know i just you
know two decades ago it is but now you
could talk about it openly but like
i hear that you know there was some
toxicity on the set did you ever feel
that or was it very loose for you and
you didn't notice anything going on i
didn't by the time i got there in season
six it was everybody had kind of found
their foothold
the the
the rocky uh
aspects of of you know on-set dating and
stuff had kind of settled
everybody knew their their place and so
it was um
it was a little more settled when i got
that me and ollie hudson came in for the
final season
uh again i think just add some window
dressing
old window dressing and uh um i worked
predominantly with michelle um i played
her was she great what a great actress
she was she and she was she was another
one that kind of
is not um
uh at least then she she she wasn't
overly welcoming
uh she was more of an introvert right
you had to earn her respect a little bit
who was the one that was just very
welcoming i'm guessing josh
yeah josh and i hung out quite a bit
kerr kurt smith was great right uh josh
and i hung out quite a bit he and i um
you know we run into each other all the
time and
uh he's good dude great dude um
james i didn't work with too much but
also very nice katie was very sweet
uh they all busy phillips uh was was
you know loads of fun uh but michelle
was reserved she's very reserved i i
and i i kind of
i didn't take that as a challenge but i
was just like
okay well i just have to be patient and
i'll hopefully earn her respect and one
day she just
because we'd go back to the cash chairs
and she'd just bury herself in a book
and there was it wasn't a whole lot of
like so it's kind of like kristen crook
from smallville she'd bury herself in a
book she was just very
yeah yeah just kind of doing her own
thing she was very pleasant but just
like you know
didn't want to chit chat a ton unless
she talked to her right but i'll never
forget but but kristen i think was like
yeah she was pleasant if engaged but she
wasn't going to
hey jensen how was your weekend no i
heard jessica alba's house
what'd michael weatherly think of that
jesus um
so uh yeah when michelle was a little
different she
you know
if if i was like i was trying to maybe
make some conversation and
you know i get
one answer one word answer is kind of a
thing um i'm like okay that's fine i'll
just give her space you know she's doing
her thing she was kind of she never got
mixed up in the drama that was on that
set right she never fooled around with
anybody i don't think so uh i believe
that is that not true i think josh
jackson and her dated for a while oh
very possible could happen but again by
the time i got there all of that was
kind of
had settled right now and everybody
sizzled out and they're kind of
finishing up but i remember one day she
i i don't know if i'd finally kind of
earned a little bit of respect from her
um but she goes what are you doing
tomorrow and it was a day off that we
both had
i was like nothing is in wilmington
north carolina and she says uh
okay meet me at this record shop at two
o'clock i was like okay
so i go down and it's just like this is
back in like cds right michael weatherly
is there it's uncomfortable it's like
what are you doing i don't care
you again
and and she and we walk out i meet her
there and she walks in she knows the the
clerk and it's like this cool vinyl
cd shop
and she goes grab a basket
i was like okay so i grab a little
shopping basket and then i just follow
her not very little words spoken and she
just goes through and starts grab
pulling cds and throwing them in my
basket
and it was like for her or for you to
listen to it was for me to listen to and
it was like it was like spoon and the
shins and like you know train yeah i
don't know if training was out i don't
think train was early training it
sounded like it could have been yeah um
and uh
and so she you know i was maybe maybe
five or six cds and she was like uh
she was like okay
there you go that was your day with
michelle she's like that's that's that's
me
and i was like okay it was like her
basic it was her olive branch of like if
you wanted to get to know me this is
this is what i do this is how i roll
this is what
this is the avenue of of of
you know to to
to know me right but you know this is
the music so i went home and i listened
to all that music and the next day i
showed up and we had wonderful
conversations for the rest of the
semester right because now you can
relate you're listening to the same
things you have something to talk about
otherwise it's just like right and she
was hot guys she was like
she was still a teenager i think at that
time wow really she was young yeah
because she started on that show like 15
or so oh my god
um
but uh very sweet and we we ended up
having a really good time and yeah that
was a good experience for me i i had no
bad things to talk about you know people
always ask like tom and myself like did
you ever think that smallville would go
10 years yeah and we always say no how
could you possibly know that other than
i saw the pilot and i thought wow this
is the best thing i've ever done and
this is really cool and it's got it
could have some legs yeah but i mean i'm
sure you've been asked this question a
long time but with supernatural when you
saw the pilot was it something you go oh
this is going to last 14 years or did
you think oh we got a shot to last a
season or two uh probably the latter i i
remember going like man this is a really
great script
um
this is and then seeing the pilot up and
then we got picked up i was like this is
this is this is
some best stuff i've ever been a part of
we might get three seasons out of this
wow yeah what did you love the most
about it what was it like if you
remember
like what just made you think i like i
like this and what did you like about it
um i liked i loved the character
because he the the two characters and
this is no secret
uh were
were written very much like a luke
skywalker and a han solo right and
the figurine sitting next to you there
uh
indiana jones han solo those were the
characters even though you know
both played the same actor those are the
kind of characters that i just
dreamed of playing
then
dean was very much that and he was
modeled after uh han solo and
so
the character was one but then also this
fantastical world
dark that's dark
and
not bound by reality and we could get
away with doing whatever we wanted
um they let you improvise
or mostly it was you know you stuck to
the scrub we would always get script but
then if we needed to
spice it up or get some nuance in there
then yeah we would always they the
writers as the years as the seasons went
on the writers became very trustworthy
uh with what jared and i wanted to do
and there was i'll never forget this is
this is a
a well-known story um amongst
amongst the fandom of supernatural but
uh we got this one scene and it was it
was kind of where the brothers have a
blow up and they they're like
they part ways for a bit and they're
they they break up right the brothers
break up
and reading it it just
he and i were both bumping on it it's
like this is not
something's wrong it doesn't it's not
working and i was like well it's reading
like
it's reading like a couple breaking up
it's reading like a rom-com couple
breaking up right you know this should
be
hanks and meg ryan like
this is not
this is not sam and dean winchester
right
and jared had this freaking brilliant
idea he goes do me a favor
you read all of sam's lines i'm gonna
read all of dean's lines
i was like okay
and we did it and it
that was it
did he actually keep the lines or did
you just say you heard him say them he
heard you say his lines and then you
went back to say we flipped you flipped
the script you read his lines he read
yours and that was the scene i read his
lines as dean and he read
dean's lines as sam and and you kept
that and we went to the our director who
happened to be our producer
and we said we got a pitch for you and
he's like
bob singer he's like
bob seger singer oh i was like jesus not
moves
jesus bob singer very big bob seeger fan
very big bob we played a lot of seeger
on supernatural because of it right
is that true it's very true
so we went to him and we we you know
we're like hey bob we got we got an idea
about the scene we're about to shoot and
you know bob is uh
um
one of one of my favorite people on the
planet um
and he's just he's like just
old brooklyn
you know
new yorker like that she's what
what [ __ ] what what is this what is
this
he's like what do you guys want him so
we're like we got this we want to read
you the scene we didn't tell what we
were doing
so we just read it
where i read the other right
so we did all the dialogue he's like
yeah that sounds great what's the
problem
well we're like this right each other's
lines we just flipped the lines and he's
like oh
well do that then
that was it that was it and that's how
we did it
and it worked it worked fantastic jared
with a little uh
glimpse of brilliance oh yeah no he gets
one or two a season one or two season
you know
there was a lot of you know
divide
amongst supernatural fandom about how
the show ended and what happened with
your character and you know there's a
divide yeah i'm sure you're aware of
this yeah what are your thoughts on it
um
i don't think there's a wrong opinion
about it i honestly don't i think that
if the people that have problems with it
are are validated and i think the people
that enjoyed it are validated i i was in
both camps
i spent time in both camps
um
and this is no secret when i uh
the very first time
we had ever heard what was going to
happen at the end of the season
jared and i flew out to la
and we went to the writers room before
the season started
and they
they all sat we all sat down and they
essentially pitched us what
they how they wanted to to wrap up the
show
which was the first time in supernatural
history that that had ever happened uh
and what was your initial reaction my
initial reaction was i don't like it
you said that right up no i didn't i i
was uh trying to be respectful i was
trying to be respectful so i i said okay
um
hmm okay i i didn't give them a an
overwhelming right response yeah i was
like okay um
i'm gonna sleep on it right because it's
that's a you know this is a big thing
like i don't want to mess this up 14
years
yeah yeah yeah
so i slept on it and
about a week went by and i just i i went
to my wife and i was like i'm just
really bumping on this like i'm just
it's just not
and and she she was like is it is it
because
uh dean dies and i'm like maybe maybe
i'm just too close to that character and
i just don't want to see him go
and i i for some reason i always thought
that if if someone was gonna go it would
be
sam as honestly as as kind of the
you know as the um
the martyr martyr i was thinking martyr
yeah and
and and dean would then be left to just
kind of
stumble through the rest of his life
right mourning his brother and his lost
family and and and it would be
you know maybe a sad existence but
that's just how it how it happened or we
would both go like a butch and sundance
kind of a thing right um
but me going and him
him continuing on just i i just didn't
it just didn't sit well with me and so
what'd you say so
uh
my wife and all her infinite wisdom said
um you should talk to somebody
outside
of of this that understands the world
and that was eric kripke who created the
world who created the characters right
who had been gone since season five he
left after season five so he'd been gone
for 10 years
but he still knew the show
clearly and kept tabs on it so i called
him and and he had not heard the you
know what what they were planning and so
i i told him and he did very he did the
same thing i did he was like
let me let me sleep on this let me just
kind of get some clarity on it and i'll
i'll uh
i'll phone you tomorrow said great
so
he ended up sending me this very
incredibly well-written email
explaining why he thought this was a
great ending
and it just put things in perspective
for me and then from then on i was on
board
really yeah so you needed an outside
source
i just think somebody gave you that
little insight so get somebody who's
separate from it who still knows it but
but who's not so connected yeah but
who's who is looking at things from a
macro uh
standpoint right and uh
and it did it just it really kind of
helped put things in perspective for me
and i'm sure i could have done that i'm
sure it could have called bob or i'm
sure could have called andrew who was
show running at that time and and
probably had a similar conversation but
i just wanted somebody from an
outsider's perspective i just wanted
kind of a different viewpoint right um
to help me process that so you couldn't
come back i mean the winchesters i mean
you couldn't come back in a supernatural
spin-off or you couldn't come back in a
supernatural movie dude it's
supernatural
it's supernatural of course we could of
course we can and would you there's all
kinds of ways you would
uh it was the right thing if it was the
right 100
again i love i love
that this character and i love the story
of these two brothers and i love what it
what it stands for right and i love the
world that they live in
and the and the the family that they
have acquired through their years like i
just there's there's so much love and
attachment to to that show there's
there's a reason that it went 15 years
and it could have gone longer did you
cry your face off when it ended
um
no
because it wasn't i wasn't sad
um i was
it was emotional pride
of like looking back and like look at
what we did
that's that was the feeling that the
overwhelming feeling that i had was more
of like
look at this amazing thing that we built
right
that we did together
this is it was just just emotional pride
so you didn't tear up in the last scene
with jared this is our last scene
together the
they didn't switch lines give each other
a kiss
no we we had we had well i hadn't he had
his hand in my pants but that was other
than that but that was below frame
um
no the the the final day we had kind of
already processed and it wasn't it
wasn't really a big emotional day
um
the emotional scene came
a few days earlier
which was when dean dies and says
goodbye to sam and basically like you
gotta let me go
that one was
that was heavy hard
oh yeah i mean he yeah he and i were
those were
those were it was a strong mixture of
of
character performance tears and
actor emotional real tears wow yeah you
know um i know how close you and jared
are and i love the guy and i know you're
gonna direct a walker episode coming up
coming up so i'll talk about that but
you know i know that there was that you
and daniel created a you know a an idea
to do a prequel for supernatural
right and it was written about
and then jared posted online that he you
know this is the first i've heard about
it and he was a little bit upset yeah
how did that go about um it was
well
for most for those who know me know that
i'm i'm
extremely superstitious when it comes to
a few things and one of those is
and this is probably something that that
a lot of actors shares like we don't
talk about auditions until we got the
role 100
you know yeah i i learned that very
quickly when i'd call mom and dad back
home
and they'd be like what are you working
on and be like oh i'm going out for this
one audition and i've got this other
audition for this show and
my mom still asked me if i got saving
private ryan see yeah it's like no yeah
my mom isn't it's over did you hear
about pearl harbor are you did you get
it it's like it was you know 15 years
ago
no
no it's not happening right right so i i
i that's you know something
people who aren't in the industry may
may not understand but it is it is just
simply something that it's an unwritten
rule that you just you don't talk about
[ __ ] until
until it's a done deal until the ink is
right
and
this was my first venture into
uh producing and and creating content uh
and
i didn't i didn't want to jinx it at any
cost so i should divulge any information
to anybody so i shut up about it only
the people that had to know knew
and i wasn't trying to keep it a secret
for any other purpose other than than
superstition right um
i just i'm like if i don't talk about it
i got a better chance of this happening
right and
more often and i i definitely
had people that i was you know
excited to tell uh jared being
number one on that list
uh mom being number two sorry mom
um
and uh
and then and then it it it was getting
close to getting to the point where it
was like oh this is really happening the
network the studio had signed off on it
now the network was was getting involved
uh we still didn't have a script in fact
we just got it script last week wow so
this was back in february or something
so it was very early on i mean we had a
concept essentially
and uh
you know when you start getting studio
and you start getting network involved
you start getting a lot of people a lot
of eyes in a lot of years there's
assistance there's you know publicist
there's executives and people talk and
and it got out and you know deadline has
they've got moles everywhere right you
know he probably works for deadline ryan
ryan what for deadline do you work for
the [ __ ] deadline dude
he's over here taking extensive notes
i've noticed it's different today yeah
it's yeah it's my deadline look it's
your deadline beer this is this is what
this is what a deadline yeah this is
this is what a deadline is the deadline
template
this is what a mole looks like
all right so they so they they they
dropped they you know i'm on set in
toronto and i get a phone call that
they're like hey deadline uh caught wind
of it and they're they're throwing
something out this afternoon i was like
what
so
i quickly had to like write up a little
something uh and i'm getting called from
uh network and i'm getting called from
studio
you know head of pr at warner brothers
and i'm getting call from my agent my
manager and like everybody and i'm like
running back and forth and i'm on a new
set
and they don't do cell phones on this
set right which is just something that
the i like that yeah i do too i have no
problem with it but
and they also stay on set
right so there's they just sit they sit
there all day long the actors
and they stay off the the social media
and the phones and stuff so if you need
to make a phone call or you need to
check something you got to go back out
to the trailers which
is sometimes they're far
sometimes they're far but it's also you
know it's slightly frowned upon right
and i'm the new guy and i don't want to
like ruffle feathers like i'm i'm a
guest in this these people's house so
i'm going to play by their rules
so
i go back and i look at my phone and i'm
like trying to come up with a
you know a little blurb
that i can send out
to you know like hey we're deadline boom
excited
all the while not even thinking like oh
[ __ ] i haven't told
abcde or you know
i i haven't like
and that that was something that i was
gonna be excited to do right
um but again i'm scrambling network's
calling me like hey you gotta you know
throw something out there so i did and
i'm like boom okay there it goes and i
run back on the set
and now i'm working now that's out of
out of mind because i've got to be
present in the scene that i'm doing so
i'm not even thinking about it
i get back out to my trailer at a
certain point to check and make sure
that you know that went okay and
it was like emails of like
congratulations text message of
congratulations and then it all just
kind of turned south
i was like and then and i had a long
text from jared and he was really bummed
out and i just i just remember my heart
just sank i was just like
[ __ ]
because he tweeted something right
well that
that kind of he's like this is news to
me no one even told me this right right
yeah i
you know in hindsight like
that that could have been a a step that
was avoided but he did it and you know
it happened and we dealt with it and he
and i were
great like i mean that was right i was
brothers i wish he had just called me
and said
yo dude what the [ __ ] why don't you tell
me you're doing this and i would have
been like oh
okay yes yeah i i you know you're right
i i've been on work i've been working
and this has been happening and and it
it's it's
way early in the process
it's not even a done deal we don't even
have an outline
uh i just didn't want to talk about it
or tell people and jinx it
um and and he totally got it and he was
he's understood and he you know he was
like i probably shouldn't attack that
you know
like i was i was surrounded by people
and it was late night and
had a few drinks and i just i kind of
lashed out and so and i got it i was
like yeah look man i i don't your
feelings are valid yeah your feelings
are totally valid and i i messed up i
should have told you i should have at
least clued you in before the world
found out and that's on me well how far
does this the prequel go back i mean are
we talking about dean and sam as younger
teenagers no no it's it's not it's not
has nothing to do with that it's uh mom
and dad as teenagers
really it's how you're a mother and
father it's the story of john winchester
of mary campbell how it all started
correct so you're not gonna even be in
it no you might do a guest star well how
i mean it's this is the it could be this
is 19.
well flash forward maybe but this is
this is early 70s when when dad got back
from nam
and
we're not even born
so
that's is it cool are you excited about
it yeah i mean we just got our first
draft of the script and you liked it
last week and it's i'm super stoked yeah
inside of you is brought to you by sonos
uh you know i love this company you know
i love this product i had them all over
my house before they were a sponsor i've
been begging cumulus to
and the ladies at cumulus agnes and
teresa
please get me sonos get sonos on as a
sponsor and finally
they do
i can't tell you how much i love sonos
you know how a lot of times you have
these clunky receivers and all you know
speakers and all these things in your
house and you could just minimize
everything and make life simple with
sonos a sono speaker that you could play
a different song in each room you could
play party mode outside you can go
listen to some of the sundays downstairs
if you know who the sundays are like the
sundays
um
it's really a wonderful product i
haven't heard anyone bad mouth sonos i
say to my friends i say you know what
sono says like oh my god of course sonos
i know sonos stonies yeah sonos man oh
my god i knew sannius yeah and then
that was awesome sonos has a new product
called rome and uh this is such a sleek
cool product
and
it looks amazing in my home and i really
urge you to check it out uh it's in my
office
and uh the sound is unbelievable that's
just the thing you don't need these big
speakers these big bulky things in your
house anymore these ceiling speakers you
got
you got sonos and rome is just really
amazing and uh durable and um
i really like it sonos roam is the ultra
portable smart speaker that allows you
to bring the sonos experience everywhere
you go rome weighs less than a pound and
its premium durable design makes it
perfect for the home and for on the go
thanks ryan you know when you're at home
roam connects to your wi-fi network and
the rest of your sonos system and then
automatically pairs with your phone on
bluetooth when you're on the go for a
seamless experience using automatic true
play tuning roams smartly adapts to your
surroundings and whatever you're
listening to and creates sound that's
astonishingly detailed and perfectly
balanced control roam using the app
apple airplay 2 or your voice with an
amazon alexa or google assistant with
sonos you can start with one speaker
expand your system over time like i have
i think i have nine in my house all
sonos speakers connect over wi-fi so you
can group speakers in different rooms
and play music throughout your home you
know i love sonos again because it's
like if you got a girlfriend or whatever
you know it's like she's like i want to
listen to whatever and you're like well
i want to listen to like this and you
can go well i'm going to go to my room
well your room is my room okay you go to
your our room i'm going to go downstairs
and listen just imagining you in a wig
yeah well there you go i've been in wigs
before i've been in a lot of movies
sonos we love our sonos please go to
sonos.com to learn more you will not be
sorry sonos.com
you directed an episode
of walker
how did that i'm going to you're going
to direct it
did they just ask you yeah jared was
like uh i know somebody i trust
so he he went and you know he's he's big
man on campus there uh he's got a he's
got ep credit and um and he's he's doing
the work and he's confided in me a few
times of like why am i why did i double
my workload this is ridiculous jesus um
but he much like much like me he's uh
he's just a a workhorse and we just we
just like to work we're gluttons for
punishment
you do you like to just work and work
and work is this something that denial
your wife sort of like go ahead i don't
know is this
we're not live but when is this
uh i don't know exactly whenever you
wanted to really we could just decide
that um i'm literally leaving in
a week and then a week but we can change
to do a movie
to doing a movie to do a film for the
next four weeks
and that and i was like i gotta have a
heart out
so i wrap
uh walker on the 27th and i start prep
on walker on the 28th of october so
you're shooting to the 27th of october
and then you and then immediately go to
austin to uh
to start how do you do that how do you
psychologically physically mentally all
these things
how do you how are you able to just keep
working and working yourself in the
ground you must have an amazing amazing
stamina
um
yeah i i it's just mentality it's like i
i i don't like to be idle i i i have to
be
i have to be kind of busy do you get
anxious do you get anxiety
no
you really don't not really
because you you stay how do you do that
what do you do to keep that those dark
thoughts out do you just work out a lot
do are you constantly meditating or what
are you doing no i just i just stay busy
i just stay busy
um
and it is long i feel like as long as
i've got things happening
then i'm doing something productive
right
then i'm cool
it's when i stop being productive and
and become idle that i get
i just get antsy i don't get anxiety i
just kind of get antsy like yeah like
when you were in your hotel room before
you were shooting i think supernatural
the final go you were just like had this
stuck stuck there for 14 days and you
were going a little crazy well um yeah
or even the boys like when i went up to
toronto i had to do a 14-day quarantine
um but again
i set my mind to okay i've got 14 days
now
to work out to study
to get prepared to go into a completely
different environment
and try to kick ass right so it forces
you to focus yeah
that's amazing also look you're doing
batman the long halloween
it's already out
right right you're the voice of batman
you get to say i am batman yeah
how was that was that just a really
exciting thing to do dude it's it's like
childhood bucket list [ __ ] man
you're a batman now i got paid to say
i'm batman
did you immediately say when they asked
you yes i'm in
they i had done a uh i'd done a previous
film called uh um under the red hood and
i played jason todd
who was uh
the red hood
uh but it was another batman um
from the batman world right
and uh bruce greenberg was playing
batman at that point
and er was the voice
um
so i was i was playing jason todd it was
he's like an ex robin
character right uh
and i got i got the call a couple years
later um saying hey they they're
interested in bringing you back for
another uh another batman feature and i
was like oh cool doing
as jason todd as red hood
they're like
now you're getting the upgrade kid
just like that and i was yeah
give me a little batman how do you sound
well there's it's interesting because
you've got the
you've got the bruce wayne who's about
like this very clean
and that's bruce wayne right
but then you've got batman
batman's way down here
batman i'm batman i'm batman did you
just love it saying that come on did you
want to say it a hundred times can i do
another take
i'm batman
no one can say i can't say that i can't
say i've said i'm batman
i wish i could but i know it again it's
it's it's like childhood check mark like
childhood dream checkmark when you were
renegotiating supernatural real quick
question yeah did did you call tom
welling he said you called him and you
talked about like he helped you out a
little bit that's [ __ ] he's lying i
figured he was um no i i did i i talked
to tom a few times about
about that because he was
he was really the only person i knew
that had been in that position
uh
and and a lot of the stuff that that i
got from tom
i was able to implement
um
and kind of grandfather in to the show
and it was all because i was it was all
reflection of his experience with
smallville right uh one of the things
being
um
we got uh jared and i got got driven to
and from set
that saves you i can't believe that
wasn't done before and they don't do
that like everybody everybody's
self-driving yeah um and we had our own
our own driver
and
and the argument to have that because we
got some pushback on it and i just used
a tom story
and i said you're tired i said listen
tom season one
he pulled over the side of the road and
slept in his car
this is your number one
actor on the show this is your
quarterback
and you're allowing him
you're working him so much
and making him so tired he's giving all
he can all day long and he gets in a car
and behind the wheel and you trust that
he's gonna make it back to you the next
day fine it's on you you you gotta i was
like you gotta take care of your
quarterback yeah
yeah like that's that's a that's a
simple fix
and so i i i had said that
in jared's next meets like
yeah
yeah yeah i'm uh with him right oh yeah
i concur yeah
so it worked out and that was it
basically yeah i was that was kind of
the analogy and i said i said you know
where you got two quarterbacks here
um i just ask that you you protect us
and and keep us safe and and get us to
and from work in a in a safe way and
that was it the producer was like okay
uh the boys yep this is exciting
you grew a beard you're playing soldier
boy i did not know i could grow a beard
like that boy you grew a beard man yeah
that sucker was that pisses me off when
i see a perfect beard
[ __ ] i have this awful beard i
had more products
for the for the for the
the beast on my face than i had for any
other part of my body they they
conditioned your beard i had well i mean
yeah i had you got to get the you got to
get the shampoo that's special for beard
you got to get the conditioner that's
special for bread you got to get the
beard bomb there's beard butter there's
uh there there's the wax there's the
oil i mean i it was like i i didn't know
it was my first time into this world so
i'm just buying different ones and
trying different ones i had a whole side
of my my bathroom was taken over by
beard [ __ ]
and you had the beard for the entire run
no no they um
they
so what happens is i don't think this is
any secret i'm not getting anything away
uh
they they kind of
find me
um and i've been essentially in
captivity for a while
and so when they do i'm bearded and i
look like castaway uh but then they uh
then they clean me up and i get my
superhero outfit back on and i i go to
town now essentially the show is
superheroes are celebrities controlled
by a corporation and they're not good
people ultimately is that right right
and so i'm guessing or do you not want
to give it away
that you're playing a character that's
not really that good of a guy no he's
he's a he's a jackass he's a jackass
yeah and it's like a captain america
kind of character it is yeah so
it's dark because ryan you were saying
how bloody it is oh my god because i'm
going to watch it now that you're in it
oh bro i heard it's great anyway you'll
love it yeah they just got uh nominated
for emmy for best drama jesus yeah up
against i didn't want to watch that the
crown and bridgeton and this is us
because i hear that there's some dark
[ __ ] on this this had to be very
exciting for you to kind of like uh
it is it's great i was a fan of the show
before uh we even talked about me coming
on um and in fact the whole way that
happened was
i was calling eric kripke who is the
show runner in the boys right who also
created supernatural right and i i was
calling him to talk to him about the
winchesters
and at the end of our conversation
because i had because he he owns that ip
right because he created those
characters so i literally had to call
him and get
him to sign off now now they kicked it
over to business affairs at warner
brothers and his lawyers and they got
together and they
you know they did their thing but uh but
i need to get crippy to sign off on us
using those characters for this this uh
this prequel
and then in that conversation at the end
of that conversation
i said well hey man supernaturals uh
we're wrapping up here um
or it's or it's gonna be wrapped up uh
because we were this was during the the
break when we broke
for covid and it was before we came back
to shoot our our last two episodes
and uh i was like i'm gonna be
unemployed pretty soon so whenever
you're ready for me to come on over the
boys just let me know and he was like
hey man if you want to come over to the
boys i'll i'll
i'll write you a part
just like that i got no problem with
that and i'm like yeah dude i'd love to
come over there it's like i love that
show and he goes
well hang on he's like
i don't know if he's like
i don't know if i want to bring in for
just like a bit part
he's like there's another role
i'll tell you what i'm going to send you
over some material take a look at it
let's talk tomorrow i was like okay so
he sends me over soldier boy and i read
that i read this this material and i was
like
yes
absolutely what made you say yes who do
i have to kill right what was it about
the soulja boy character that you like
had to do it he was he's this
uh
i mean he's a he's a grandpa right he's
from the 40s
like he fought in world war ii
and he's he's just this curmudgeon
bigoted
[ __ ]
and he's you know he doesn't age so he's
this young
or this this you know 40 year old
superhero
uh who's really 80 years old or 90 years
old
and there's there's just so much
material there and you'll see what i
mean when you see that when you see the
the show but um you know he just he has
uh he's a taste for
for people that were of his
of his era
right um
and
so it was uh it was a no-brainer but
again
this was something that the studio that
sony was talking to some much bigger
names than me
and uh and wanted to bring in for season
three and so eric was like look i i know
you can do this he's like but we're
gonna have to convince
the the you know the powers and how did
you convince them so
did you read he's like you're gonna put
yourself on tape and i was like great
i'll do that
so i did and i sent it to him only
and then he noted me of course i did it
again said it to him he noted me again
yeah we did we went back and forth about
four times and he was like okay he's
like i'm i'm cool if you're cool like i
can take this up the up the chain here
and
uh see what kind of response we get i
was like
look if you're gonna go to bat for me i
want to give you the biggest bat i can
right um so tell me if there's anything
else i can do he's like you're good
and so he went to bat for me and then
boom that was it but i i worked for it
it wasn't just like a hey we want to
bring you on for season three right no i
had to earn this one you have to earn a
lot i think people think that you know a
lot of things are given to you no and
you have to fight for them and this is
how i had to do it this is interesting
you know uh you know the show right yeah
so
the audition scene that i had to do was
a scene with soldier boy and butcher
played by carl urban carl i saw you
golfing with him on instagram good guy
um good good new zealand boy will he
come on the podcast carl yeah if you can
dig him up from uh down under is that
where he is oh he's he's in new zealand
uh yeah all right if he ever if he ever
surfaces this way yeah he probably would
um
now you got a lot to talk about with him
i'm sure that's that's he's got some
underlying stuff like he's kind of dark
i think yeah but i mean he's like part
of the bourne uh movies he was just yeah
star trek yeah yeah like you know
he's got he's got a lot of uh wasn't he
dread too you dread yeah geez so good
he's really talented really carl's great
but go ahead i wanna hear this i'm a big
fan and more importantly a friend now so
that's cool um so this so the scene is
between butcher
and soldier boy well we're in we're in
court we're in lockdown this is summer
and all i've got is
two three-year-olds a seven-year-old and
my wife
and i'm like no one can read butcher
so
i pre-recorded butcher
doing a kind of doing my butcher voice
and then had denial off to the side
pressing play and pause so i was
giving my lines a soldier boy and then
hearing my pre-recorded butcher lines
back to me right but this is the kind of
[ __ ] you got to do when you're trying to
get a job that's awesome
i i've done [ __ ] like that too of course
or you just you know you
you kind of read a line a certain way
and you give a few spaces in between so
you can respond right you just kind of
get that feel of it but
you really wanted this yeah yeah and
it's a whole season you're in the whole
season
and how many episodes in the season
there's eight
do you think you'll come back
uh i don't know
i don't know it's the gave me a smile
the door is not closed we'll put it that
way right but you do know the creator
uh yeah the show runner is definitely a
good friend
so it'll it'll depend on how it all cuts
together if if you know but are you
hearing good things did they he has he
called and said hey it looks great man
yeah
have you seen anything uh i haven't seen
anything cut together um
but uh
but i've gotten some some good feedback
from from those that
those that need to be impressed what's
the one role you would you want or
what's the one marvel movie or dc movie
that you'd love to be a part of
oh gosh
um
well there is a there is a dc property
that i'm
that currently uh developing right now
with with warner brothers and uh
uh and some other good partners that uh
that i've got i've got my fingers
crossed for but again i'm not gonna talk
about it because
you don't want to jinx it no you're not
going to jinx it i sent him a script
that he really loves i do like maybe who
knows maybe what happens from there i do
love that script it's good it's a fun
script yeah uh this is called [ __ ]
talking with jensen knackles rapid fire
wrap this up love it angela f what's
been your favorite part about working on
the boys your favorite part
um
just getting to play in a different
world uh you know playing in the same
world for 15 years
uh i forgot what it was like out there
so getting around getting around
different creative people
um
finding
finding nuance with storytelling that's
just that's why we that's why we do
that's why i do it i like a different
character playing a different character
in a different world and telling a
different story it's just fun stuff
you're excited i could tell yeah i'm
excited for you dana asks what is the
most ridiculous thing a fan has done to
catch your attention you ever get a boob
shot any solicited solid illiciting of
sex
well i was i i was a king of bacchus one
year which is uh mardi gras uh king
uh who rides in the parade so oh well
there were there were uh
boobs unmentionable
things happening to get my attention
right but it wasn't because they were
fannies because they wanted me to throw
freaking beets
[Laughter]
which by the way if you've never ridden
in a mardi gras parade
i
urge can not stress
the the experience and the amazing
experience the amazingness of it uh it's
that fun it is
it is mind it's like life-changing
you hear that ryan yeah let's get on
that all right let's talk to my agent
yeah
uh but like did you ever get like
because i mean i i imagine the fans i
mean 14 years on a show
uh you know
my fans are fantastic but do you ever
get any intense fans or really emotional
fans who just like are so in awe of you
that just like
makes you uncomfortable or have they
ever made you cry or like have you ever
heard a story where you kind of sure
yeah i mean that's that's one of the
beautiful things about uh
being a part of a
of a show or
a film or something like this that has
such a
uh intense fan base
is
you get to have a connection with a
with a body of people that you probably
normally would never have any any
connection to and so it you have this
common interest
um
that is that for some people you know
there's that that old adage that uh you
know when you're on set it's like hey
everybody calm down we're not curing
cancer here right right right right
and we're not we're not curing cancer
we're making a tv show right
but
i would argue that somebody with cancer
is lying in a hospital bed right now
watching a television show
that's making them laugh or that means
something or that means something to
them yeah or that they find some
inspiration from and it helps them maybe
fight a little bit more
and that's the kind of stuff that that
gets me emotional i love it yeah emily
asks what's your favorite storyline in
supernatural
favorite storyline um
well i mean obviously the just
the long lead storyline of the two of
the brothers and what they what they go
through is is certainly what the entire
show was built on so i've clearly that
that is uh
the most important and the most favorite
storyline of all but i would say of kind
of the peripheral storylines um
i would say one that that i truly love
that i wish would have gotten to play a
little bit more with was uh dean and
purgatory
um
with uh with benny and uh and cass i
thought that was
it was just shot differently it felt
different it was a different kind of
world we were in we were fighting for
survival you wanted it it was like it
was like this post-apocalyptic feel to
it yeah we were just covered in blood
and mud
and it was just it had a different feel
and i just i enjoyed that i love it yeah
kelly asks have you ever had a real life
supernatural experience or ghost
encounter and did it freak you out um
um
i i have i have probably but
i have this uh
i have 15 years of training
[Laughter]
and it's given me a horribly false sense
of security
around anything
that could possibly be supernatural
right and so if there's like a bump in
the night
in my mind it's not like oh my god what
was that in my mind is like you picked
the wrong house [ __ ]
that is a clip right there for the
podcast right there you picked the wrong
house [ __ ] uh raj what's the
most afraid you've ever been
um
i i'm just gonna say this because it's
the first thing that popped in my head
i'm sure i could probably uh dwell on
this and think of some more examples but
can i guess sure having your first kid
uh no okay
um
no because there's there's a there's a
bliss to that
there's a there's it's
um
i mean yeah i would say right now if you
ask me currently what is my greatest
fear right
it is
something happening to my kids sure and
me not being there
um but i think the scaredest i've ever
been
was
uh and just because we had a huge
anniversary was 9 11.
because i was up in vancouver doing dark
angel
and
i thought we were under attack
and i was like
i gotta get back home
i gotta protect my family wow yeah that
was problem and watching all that like
20-year anniversary stuff was
it was pretty heavy that was a
terrifying time terrifying time i didn't
remember exactly where i was absolutely
shooting smallville as well i think
everybody can i think it's one of those
moments in history where it's like where
were you yeah and if you i mean now
we've got
you know now now get fans of
supernatural weren't even alive
uh
yeah right when that happened but if you
were alive and you were you know you
knew what was up you knew where you were
i mean it was like when you know kennedy
got shot or when
the space shuttle space shuttle exploded
you know it's like people there's just
some those that is one of those things
in history where it's just like and i
was terrified yeah because i not of like
not scared of the enemy but scared that
like
i'm not gonna be like i'm not there for
my kids i'm removed and and i'm not
there for no i mean i was a kid at that
point i was you know 20 oh yeah you
don't have anything yeah i want to get
home and be all your family your family
right your brother my sister and my my
you know
and i was like oh my gosh i'm gonna be
like
stuck in another country yeah and we're
under attack
then my dad was like stay there
and that scared me
because we didn't know nobody knew what
was going on no nobody had any idea is
every major city now gonna get hit like
you didn't know that you just didn't
know
uh dude this has been awesome it was
always easy with you right well i i hope
not
well not that easy no it's not but uh
you know crazy
i mean you got so much going on you just
finished the boys just finished the boys
you got the direct and walker director
were you doing a movie before that i'm
about to i'm about to hop off and do a
uh a movie and and
wait till
that gets announced because it's not
even i literally just just closed i'm
gonna get it out yesterday
i would assume the next week or two okay
so it won't but it's a movie it's a
western
my dream i know me too what's it called
uh
i think they're playing i don't think
they have a title yet right but you're
doing a western anybody in it that uh i
get excited about it's basically um a
girl from lost no uh uh alec baldwin
uh
is an old gunslinger who was thought to
be dead and he's got a huge reward on
his head and he comes he services
and causes all kinds of [ __ ] and then
has to get on on the run and i'm the i'm
the us marshal leading the posse to
track him down another beard
if i had the time but i don't think i've
got the time maybe that that scruff
they said just don't shave until we see
you
so how exciting is that yeah i think i'm
about to spend the next month on a on a
horse
with alec baldwin yeah
jeez man yeah how much fun is his life
i mean he's got a beautiful wife
beautiful kids he's got a bar in in uh
where austin austin what's called
uh family business beer company family
business beer coming i still want a
t-shirt or a hat or something hell yeah
i'll bug you about it you're wearing a
sun spin shirt of mine i just gave you
that lift it up show it to the audience
let me see this thing
boom
boom howdy and what would you tell your
fans out there all 8.8 million to watch
this to watch and listen to this podcast
even when you're not on it jensen uh
look it's it's it's it's [ __ ] it's
rosie
who doesn't want to listen to rosie come
on guys he's he's got uh you know he's
got all the talent in the world i love
jensen this has been a real treat i love
you i wish you continued success man i
love seeing you happy
you always seem happy you always seem
like you're just doing your thing it's a
good life that's a good life it's a good
life you know um i've been very very
fortunate and i've got a lot to be
thankful for you want to say anything to
ryan um no cause he's gonna give it
straight to deadline yep that's probably
true all right
buddy thanks for being here man you're
beautiful you're beautiful that's
awesome
you know we didn't we didn't talk about
uh because i had interviewed him before
about the incident that happened on the
set of the movie that he was doing that
he talked about on the podcast
you know with the shooting the
accidental death and yeah
so i didn't get a chance to do that and
uh i think that he had talked about it
enough he had tweeted about it enough i
think that he didn't i don't think
you know you you needed to hear more of
that right um i think he made it pretty
clear on his twitter how he felt and um
it was pretty emotional and uh you know
so i'm
i was thinking about calling him up and
saying hey dude you can i just get an
excerpt you know yeah something about
that and but i didn't i said what the
what the [ __ ] you know leave them alone
yeah that's probably okay yeah i think
so too
cheese yeah it was tragic but uh yeah
hey guys uh it's it's a new year i hope
you're treating yourself right i hope
you're doing good things for yourselves
don't be hard on yourselves we're all
flawed i'm flawed you know ryan's flawed
not as flat as me no i got it nailed i
got everything nailed
to a tee uh better help man you're still
doing better help still doing it i love
it still still i need some more better
help after that uh hawaiian trip oh yeah
it's been helpful oh yeah
oh
yes
uh make sure you follow us make sure you
write a review
please subscribe to the podcast we got
good stuff coming up we got great guests
coming up uh remember stage it i'll be
performing virtually
um uh on stage it january 29th 2 pm and
6 6pm show you can go to sunspin.com
s-u-n-s-p-i-n-sunspin.com
and get tickets there along with merch
sunspin merch
um and if you go to the inside of you
online store you can get great merch i
even have this new script it's a popular
small little script lexmas so i printed
out some copies and you can get my
autograph on there and fun
funko pops and uh
lunchboxes smallville lunchboxes along
with a lot of cool inside of you gear if
you like the podcast and you want a
tumblr signed by me or just you know a
hat or whatever so check that out i'll
be in limouli if i pronounce that right
limoulicon
uh in mexico in march
um
and join patron uh patreon it's patreon
p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot com slash inside of
you become part of a community that
supports the podcast in so many ways and
uh speaking of that why don't we get
into the top tiers
who give the most uh
to the podcast and really you know help
the podcast out in so many ways and
they're just so loyal and some people
have been with me for a couple years now
i think
like two years wow since i started well
since i started patron right so however
long that is probably two years yeah
probably two years but they
they stick with me some people can't
some people have financial problems or
whatever if they don't want to give i'm
like [ __ ] dude thank you thank you for
giving a dollar thank you giving a
quarter thank you for whatever you give
to the podcast it's just you know it's
[ __ ] you know it's not funny about joe
rogan here
man that's a good thing yeah it's a good
thing man he went a little you know yeah
that's a whole other what what happened
i don't know it's just i think some
people just with too much
confidence
yeah i think that's what it is i don't
know because he was always nice to me
when i did stand-up and he was uh
i always enjoyed a lot of his interviews
i think he's a great interviewer but uh
it just seems he's
too intense these days
it's just weird i don't know what to say
i'm not going to badmouth him i'm just
going to say it's just different he's
just a different rogan defrogan
but who cares that's fine all my best to
him okay if you listen to this which he
wouldn't he'd be like who the [ __ ] are
you you're nobody and i'd say we're
doing great over here in our little
podcast space yeah we're doing just fine
we're doing just yeah that's true don't
compare yourself to other people guys
don't compare yourselves to other here
are the top patrons
uh nancy d
leah yes sarah v little lisa you kiko
jill e brian ay
yep
nico p jerry r w that's correct robert
i'm b
jason w kristen k amelia oh allison l
raj c emily
f
s yes cjp sorry i said that's fine
jennifer and
yes stacy l yeah
yeah jen
crap
s yes correct jamal
f yeah yeah janelle
b correct
mike e yeah el don supremo 99
dude you haven't missed one yet this is
the best you've ever done santiago
ah c no uh m yes jeez chad
when what's santiago chile that's what i
was trying to do yeah what chad w dude
leanne p janine r maya p maddie s
belinda and
chris
h yes and dave
h correct spider-man chase sheila g brad
d ray h liliana
r a a correct michelle
uh k
talya
m betsy
d correct laura
l
and chad l rachel
nathan
g missed his first one t it's e oh well
dude that was stunning there might have
been a couple of you guys that's from
memory do you see that he's got a
a couple of hints that you can't see
nathan e marion meg kay janelle p dan
ends big stevie w angel and marianne and
c cory k super sam coleman g devnets and
michelle a jeremy c sebastian k
gavinator david c john b brandy devore
camille s
the c
joey m willie f christina e adelaide n
omar i
lo
lana lina lina lena is lena isn't it who
lena ann eugene and leah i love you guys
chris p nikki g cory patricia m
maria and
heather l jake b bobbitt
and ed
asner no eddie oh eddie what's up eddie
nice to meet you today nice to meet you
yeah nice to meet you nice to meet you
lovely man lovely man uh guys uh i i
really adore you and thank you for
listening to the podcast this has been
uh
it's fun it's another year and i can't
tell you how freaking hard it is to get
guests to do the show it's like me
constantly bothering people but we've
got some great ones this year
uh great ones through through
march i think
uh getting pretty booked up you and i
are gonna we had a couple weeks off but
we're gonna get we're gonna do two next
week two the following week and then one
and one
but uh
get some in the can some good ones
leslie ann brandt from lucifer cool uh
ludwig alexander ludwig from
uh
vikings heels uh hunger games
um yes katie lutz i think is going to
come on oh i know her i hope she doesn't
bail on me jeez i don't want to do
christian bail on me no but uh you know
it's exciting let's show up in a costume
and overact yeah
well let's see
uh but it's uh
but we great stuff coming up too i can't
announce anything but i'm gonna announce
something probably in the next uh couple
weeks or months that is really exciting
and i hope you continue to join me on on
my journey this is your journey too uh
thank you for allowing me inside of each
and every one of you today from myself
michael rosenbaum in the hills and
myself ryan tez christian bill is a
wonderful actor by the way he is that's
what i mean he is christian bell's
wonderful uh give a little wave to the
camera we love you and thanks again for
tuning in and uh
anything else ryan that's it i think
that's it that's all go to therapy if
you need it
stop thinking you're better than
everyone
and dad i'm not just talking to you
mom
dad
my brother
my other brother my sister my whole
family hey
your brother michael goes to therapy
you better than me man
go to [ __ ] therapy and just slowly
fade out
i love you thank you
you